happy Star Wars week continues everybody
so the battlefront 2 trailer leaked so
just to avoid any conflicts I'm going to
use this screen cap style but as they
imply they're our last Jedi characters
that you can play in this game so
there'll be a much larger EA Star Wars
panel happening on Saturday will they'll
probably drop a bunch more gameplay but
basically like the gameplay here you
seen these screen caps shows off them
fighting in every era of Star Wars so
that is how you go straight from Yoda
fighting Darth Maul to Rey running on
takodana from force awakens and kylo Ren
turning so the primary campaign they're
teasing though is that you're an
imperial officer standing on Endor as
the second Death Star blows up at the
end of Return of the Jedi we have to
avenge our Emperor and they cut it with
a bunch of different footage from
different eras so like you jump to the
star killer base and as she takes off
like the real battle is just beginning
now like the end of the Empire I'll
explain that timeline too because it's
actually mapped out pretty clearly in
the aftermath book series like what
happened to the empire right after the
Battle of Endor things did not go well
for them they didn't reveal who this
character's name is but a lot of people
are wondering if she comes to the
realization slowly that the Empire is
evil because she sounds like a pretty
hardcore Palpatine flag waver so as is
the case with a lot of hero's journeys
they come to new startling conclusions
about the world they live in oh my god
things aren't the way that I thought
they were so it's just one of many
campaigns the last Jedi characters are
probably just add-on bonuses like you
play as Luke Skywalker in the original
battlefront game you play as Darth Vader
but as is the case with the first
battlefront game that was released
before the force awakens came out there
was force awakens DLC that you to play
it was really cool but they didn't have
any super spoilery storylines from the
movie so like you bike you play the last
Jedi stuff it will probably not be
spoilery
[Music]
don't let that take flight drive
I may take another hour
because this game is dropping quarter
three they don't have a hard date for it
yet they might announce that this
weekend the last Jedi isn't coming out
to the middle of December so there's no
way they would let a videogame spoil
what's happening during the movie so if
you're wondering what's going on with
last Jedi stuff in Battlefront two it's
just going to be very similar to force
awakens stuff in Battlefront one but if
you remember the scare off' rogue one
pack with the extra characters they
release when that movie came out that
was a little bit better that's what I'm
expecting from the last Jedi content
couple characters including rey kylo ren
in a couple of the new map locations
that they haven't announced like planets
that are new to the last Jedi there's a
couple new planets we'll see in the last
Jedi trailer in the next couple days
those will probably be the battle-plan
and still release as part of these big
map packs but the game looks great I've
been blind buying Star Wars triple-a
games for the last ten years or so so
it's a bit of a shut up and take my
money relationship that I have with Star
Wars but you guys can let me know what
you think of this to explain what
happened after the Battle of Endor
though they're not wrong in this trailer
the real battle began after the second
Death Star blew up what happened next is
a bit of a sideways turn so if you heard
of the guys rax character he rose to
power in this chaos it started weed out
the Imperials he felt like were not fit
for the new order they were trying to
form laying seeds for what would become
the first order so you have a lot of
people disagreeing with in what's left
of the old Empire Gaius RAC starts to
weed them out through the aftermath
series there are three books in that
over the course of that series we learn
about the Emperor's contingency plans he
has lots of bases hidden around the
galaxy with secret weapons secret
knowledge secret technology one of those
bases is on the planet jakku so Gaius
rax hatches this plant to lure the rest
of the Empire that he wants to get rid
of as well as the rebellion into a
battle over the planet jakku detonate
this giant super weapon the emperor has
blowing up the planet a bunch of the
Imperials that he hates and the new
republic fleet so that he'll be able to
slink away into the unknown regions with
the people that he's deemed ready for
his new order so it's this big culling
of both his friends and enemies that he
wants to get rid of but his
second-in-command an officer named
slowed
Isis that he's gone crazy kills him and
then takes what's left of the Imperial
fleets links off into the unknown region
and then they become the first order so
she becomes the de facto leader of
what's left until Snoke comes along so
obviously jakku itself did not get
destroyed but Gaius rax is Star
Destroyer is the one that you see at the
beginning of force awakens
[Music]
[Applause]
so things did not go well it takes the
entire aftermath book series for what
the left of the old Empire to die before
they start to become the first order but
a whole bunch of Star Wars is going to
start posting tomorrow so be sure to
subscribe to get everything I'll be
doing giveaways and all those videos so
leave all your requests for Star Wars
videos in the comments below what you
wait for that you can click here for
brand new Star Wars and you can click
here for a brand new thor ragnarok thank
you so much for watching let's high-five
I'll see you guys in the next video
hey me me me me me me
[Music]